both experts and non-experts had a role
in roman divination the experts were
members of priestly groups the harris
decays and the augurs the Hruska Ches
were supposed to be Etruscan so for much
of the history of ancient Rome this was
a foreign specialism the harris vacays
had expertise in examining the livers of
animals sacrificed before any important
occasion and in interpreting the results
one of the other specialisms of the
harris decays was the interpretation of
prodigies such as eclipses Thunderbolt
weird noises and monstrous birds like
two-headed animals these were seen as
signs of disorder in the natural world
so in the case of prodigies we're
talking about the interpretation of
things that occur spontaneously not
things that are done on purpose to
solicit a divine response the Roman
Senate made up of current and former
elected officials would consult the
Harry speakers who would give their
interpretation of The Prodigy
identifying which of the gods had been
offended or what religious offenses had
been committed the Senate would then
decide what to do to put things right
this combination of particular religious
expertise and a more general level of
experience is typical of Roman
prediction methods
you